quando i ragazzi mi hanno invitato e mi
hanno detto che l'argomento di
quest'anno era unless a meno che ho
pensato di parlarvi di due persone molto
poco due personaggi storici molto poco
conosciuti purtroppo il primo è un
filosofo medievale si chiama ad e lardo
di butt
magari qualche filosofo qualche
letterato tra di voi sicuramente lo
conosce un altro invece è in realtà
penso che nessuna effettivamente lo
possa conoscere perché un argentino e si
chiama diego armando maradona si è
chiusa la risata perché ovviamente a
napoli oltretutto tutti quanti lo
conoscono per chi non è napoletano in
sale c'è ce n'è qualcuno perché poi
magari via web ascoltare questa cosa
vorrei spiegare brevemente che cos'è
questa che è diventato ormai un'icona
parareligiosa per la città quindi che
cos'è maradona per napoli insieme al
fotografo antonio di bonito e un paio di
anni che giriamo per la città andando a
scovare quello che è rimasto di questa
icona è chiaramente abbiamo trovato cose
incredibili uno che si chiama diego
armando maradona di nome però in mollica
di cognome per esempio questo è uno dei
tanti però vi vorrei volevo dirvi due
aneddoti e poi abbiamo assistito noi
perché eravamo lì presenti fisicamente a
quarto c'è un bellissimo murales con due
facce
a destra la faccia di maradona a
sinistra la faccia dice che vara
c'erano dei bambini che giocavano di
fronte a questo muro e uno fa all'altro
ma quello la maratona e che nulla chi è
e che gli ho dato a ge maradona
questo per di un altra cosa invece che
all'inizio potrebbe fare ridere ma a me
e poi nei giorni successivi mi è un pò
scioccato pure eravamo in un bar a
soccavo
perché dice un gestore tutta una serie
di cimeli in mare maradoniani eravamo lì
erano le due di notte eravamo noi due
lui e un clochard un barbone che beveva
ed era chiaramente ubriaco alticcio
parlavamo di maradona un certo punto si
avvicina questo con jade ci dice io
iniziato a bere quando hanno affatto
fuori a maradona per l'antidoping
che effettivamente all'inizio fa ridere
piano piano poi ci pensi dc come
importante questa figura all'interno di
questa città vabbè
questo era un po una premessa per dire
quanto è importante appunto maradona per
noi torniamo al tema e quindi alla meno
che al largo di bat che è un filosofo
del xii secolo
scriveva una cosa che volevo farvi
leggere la nostra generazione ha il
radicato difetto di rifiutarsi di
accogliere tutto ciò che pare venire dai
moderni
quindi se mi sorge un idea personale se
desidero renderla pubblica attribuisco a
qualcun altro e di chiaro e il tale che
lo ha detto non io
e affinché credano pienamente a tutte le
mie opinioni
dico e il tale l'inventore non io questa
cosa quando l'ho letta ho pensato subito
alloggi al contemporaneo è pensato che
in tantissime delle nostre cose
artistiche e di pensiero quindi
filosofiche
l'unica vera e ed egemone filosofia che
c'è alle spalle il citazionismo tutto
quello che facciamo
sembra essere un continuo rimescolare di
cose già dette cose già fatte
cerchiamo sempre un padre del passato
per poter dire le nostre cose
questa è una cosa che dovete tenere a
mente e poi la riprendiamo dopo
ma passiamo a quello la sconosciuto 22
giugno 1986 quarti di finale del
mondiale di messico 86 stadio atzeca si
giocano i quarti e gioca argentina
contro inghilterra 4 anni prima c'era
stata
tra queste due nazioni la guerra delle
falkland malvinas l'argentina aveva
perso quasi 500 soldati anche se
maradona li chiama c'è da piangere se
pensi a questo si chiama ragazzi mandati
a combattere con le scarpe flash e quasi
250 inglese quindi la partita era
abbastanza sentita il primo tempo va via
in modo scialbo e al sesto minuto del
secondo tempo un difensore inglese alza
la palla
centro della propria area in area si
incontrano il portiere dell'inghilterra
che peter shilton e diego armando
maradona
peter shilton è più alto di maradona di
più di 30 centimetri maradona per
colmare quel gap alza la mano mano de
dios 1 a 0
che cosa fa la persona semplice semplice
secondo il concetto più puro che cosa fa
la persona realmente buona come maradona
secondo me cerca di farsi perdonare e
come fai a farti perdonare
potresti fare auto collo ma è una cosa
che chiaramente a un mondiale sarebbe
troppo scioccante e allora chi deve
inventare la cosa più pura l'essenza più
pura che ci può essere e maradona fa il
gol del secolo il gol del secolo per me
è una delle grandi mie mani e infatti
quando ho incontrato allenatori e ex
calciatori spesso gli chiedevo tu che ne
pensi eccetera e loro all'inizio
ovviamente chiaramente erano tutte
parole di elogio per maradona però
sottolineavano degli errori
io ne ho collezionato quattro quindi il
gol del secolo e come vediamo una
sequela di errori
sembra incredibile ma è così questo è il
primo avete visto maradona riceve il
pallone da enrico e il giusti
grande personaggio il giusti
perché poi dirà maradona ha segnato
grazie al mio assist per dire attese
grandissima anche se è stato un grande
giocatore soprattutto in quel mondiale e
lui fa quello che classicamente si
chiama un anti movimento si chiama nella
tattica contemporanee l'anti movimenti
per tutti gli allenatori tutti gli anni
d'oro i podi hanno l'anti movimento
perché porta con sé due conseguenze
negative
prima di tutto blocca il flusso ritmico
dell'azione d'attacco della propria
squadra è seconda cosa far riposizionare
la squadra avversaria così non puoi più
prenderli in contropiede quindi maradona
va verso la propria porta invece di
andare verso la porta avversaria e fa il
primo errore però riesce a dribblare e
si trova in questa situazione
e inutile che vi sto a spiegare
l'avversario a due avversari uno quello
attacca di fronte un altro che lo pressa
alle spalle e c'è quello spazio enorme
tra i due avversari in cui avrebbe
dovuto passare la palla a burruchaga
bruciarla
se avesse ricevuto la palla aveva due
possibilità o si girava e puntava alla
porta con due avversari in meno a cui
rendere conto oppure avrebbe chiuso il
triangolo con maradona con un maradona
in velocità sulla fascia e il difensore
che sarebbe dovuto girare ripartire da
da fermo quindi maradona era molto più
agevolato quindi in tutte le scuole
calcio in tutti gli allenamenti di
seriate deve essere c che ci sono su
questa faccia della terra
ogni allenatore avrebbe fermato il gioco
che avrebbe detto maradona
dovevi passare la palla burruchaga
invece maradona non la passa e si trova
in quest altra soluzione
chiaramente in un malato con un maradona
in velocità la difesa collassa tutta su
maradona e lui ha due possibilità di
assist una borouge ata che aveva seguito
l'azione di maradona è un'altra valdano
che aveva visto tutta l'azione sera ha
centrato verso la porta quindi maradona
in questo momento avrebbe potuto passare
la palla uno dei due e metterli di
fronte al portiere ma maradona non lo fa
quarto errore nella mano de dios libro
che ha scritto maradona su questo
mondiale marathon e dice scelto né in
questo momento ha fatto un errore
clamoroso è uscito troppo lentamente
verso di me e mi ha dato due angoli
quindi maradona in questo momento poteva
tirare o sull'angolo corto a sinistra di
shilton o nell'angolo lungo alla destra
di scelta quindi qua maradona
diciamo logicamente avrebbe dovuto
tirare in porta invece fa questo
quindi ci tocchi di palla se avversari
saltati ad una ad una velocità di 16,6
secondi i 100 metri quindi 100 metri in
16,6 secondi ma con la palla al piede
secondo tutti e questa è una cosa
sbagliata questo è come dire
l'esplosione estrema di un istinto
geniale che può nascere una volta ogni
mille anni
invece dopo la partita maradona dice due
cose incredibili
la prima radice sotto la doccia
burruchaga e valdano e dice io ho fatto
questa azione ho saltato tutto questi
avversari ma in ogni situazione in cui
mi trovavo con gli avversari da
affrontare
mi tenevo sempre aperta la possibilità
di passarvi il pallone quindi tutto
quello che ha fatto è stato secondo una
logica di scelta quindi non è solo
istinto e anche ragione e logica seconda
cosa che dice poi dopo la partita lo
dice il giornalista dice quando mi sono
trovato di fronte a shilton ho ricordato
ho ricordato le parole di mio fratello
il turco maradona google turco maradona
perchè sei anni prima nel 1980 malato
non era andato con l'argentina a fare un
amichevole a wembley contro
l'inghilterra proprio contro di loro
aveva fatto un'azione simile esaltando
34 avversari e si era trovato in quella
situazione in quella parte di campo di
fronte al portiere inglese che era
stepney invece di dribblarlo tira
sull'angolo lungo e la palla va fuori
quando torna a buenos aires e il turco
gli dice peluso la prossima volta che ti
trovi in quella situazione il portiere
dribla lo così è più facile segnarono
effettivamente così però deve sempre del
brive primo il portiere maradona quindi
dice una cosa incredibile che ha fatto
questa questo atto di un genio
mettendo insieme istinto ragione logica
di scelte e memoria
quindi fa un fatto d'arte secondo
facendo esplodere tutto quello che
abbiamo noi di eccezionalmente umano
proprio nell'ottica rinascimentale
quindi un fatto carte veramente
clamoroso
e poi su questo gol del secolo volevo
farvi riflettere
seguendo diciamo due dimensioni che
riguardano poi la meno che giorgio vasta
dice che questo gol è stato è stato
fatto grazie al pensiero istantanee
organizzato e se riflettiamo sul fatto
che tutto quello che facciamo
prima dobbiamo fare analisi di
fattibilità contro analisi di
fattibilità analisi di benchmark analisi
sport prima di fare una cosa facciamo
tutta una serie di analisi e invece la
cosa più bella dello sport più popolare
al mondo è stato fatto grazie al
pensiero istantanee organizzato
seconda cosa maradona dovuto affrontare
quelle che carter e chiama le difficoltà
collaborative mentre andava avanti nella
sua folle corsa le difficoltà che
trovava davanti erano sempre più
difficile e ad una velocità sempre più
sostenuta ed è in quel momento che
dobbiamo sfruttare le difficoltà per
fare cose di questo tipo
ed è qui che ad ade lardo dibatte da una
parte e maradona dall'altra si uniscono
nel mio discorso
in un'italia in un sud italia in una
città di napoli nella quale noi ci
troviamo ad affrontare difficoltà
insormontabili che ci bloccano tutte le
nostre attività
dobbiamo seguire le parole di ade lardo
di bath e seguire l'esempio di diego
armando maradona e fare e lo dico con
una sola locuzione che racchiude tutto
il discorso fare le nostre attività
d'arte attività di pensiero attività di
impresa facendo tappa nostro grazie